sometimes all it takes is one role to
change your career this is especially
true of sean william scott who became a
huge star from american pie his role as
the crude rude dim-witted dude stiffler
gained him enough notoriety that would
impact his career forever
before american pie sean william scott
himself was not a particularly
noteworthy performer he had zero feature
film credits to his name and his most
notable forays into performing were
appearing in a sunny delight commercial
and an aerosmith video at age 28 he was
working at the home depot and going on
lots of auditions and it was that
conviction that eventually resulted in
american pie part of his early struggles
can be attributed to how scott initially
saw himself scott told nbc in 2008 i
always anticipated having a career in
sports but movies were my passion i was
reminded that i could have a life
outside of being a stressed out
professional athlete i realized i could
use the same work ethic and apply it to
another career that i love i graduated
early told my coaches i wasn't going to
play sports anymore and moved to la i
got lucky got a manager and that was
that
when scott was first hired for the role
of stiffler it hadn't been written as a
major character in fact stiffler only
had a passing presence in the story
scott told entertainment weekly in 2019
the stiffler character was in two or
three scenes and he was written to be
such an
hole that i was like i don't even know
if i'd want to play this guy so i was
like i'm going to rewrite a bit of it
make him the guy you hate to love he's
probably insecure he's like the guy who
wants to be loved the most
as it would turn out his meeker scripted
presence in the production resulted in a
mediocre payday despite portraying a fan
favorite character in the sex comedy
scott only scored eight thousand dollars
for playing the role
the summer of 1999 began with moviegoers
counting down the days to the first new
star wars movie in 16 years by the end
of that season many had shifted to
discussions of the over-the-top ranch of
american pie a good deal of this talk
involved sean william scott who embodied
a classic version of abrasive masculine
immaturity and whose commitment to the
part turned what could have been a
nuisance into a fan favorite scott's
appeal as stiffler was so strong that it
even lasted well into the various pie
sequels while reviewing 2012's american
reunion roger ebert mentioned his
affinity for scots stiffler while
calling him a highlight of the film
ebert shared sean william scott has made
the role of stiffler his own and seems
able to morph his face into an entirely
new person narrowed eyes broad maniacal
grin frightening focus still with all
the zeal for seduction and adventure he
had in high school the ingenuity with
which he destroys the jet skis of two
jerks can only be admired even in these
more enlightened times a 2019
retrospective review of the original
american pie that criticized the
feature's politically incorrect elements
still found time to praise scott's
performance years removed from when
american pie first hit theaters scott
can still drum up enough praise to
remind everyone why he became the film's
biggest breakout star
in the wake of american pie scott's
status as an actor was significantly
elevated his first appearance in 2000's
original final destination was a brief
one that had him meeting a graphic
demise on screen after that scott
headlined the todd phillips feature road
trip another raunchy comedy that cast
him among a group of students who hit
the road in pursuit of sexual delights
other roles around this time included
dude where's my car and evolution all
playing off the dim horny jock persona
he suddenly had all to himself it's an
age-old hollywood question do you lean
into your notoriety and risk the
diminishing returns of repetition or do
you try to blaze a unique path and risk
alienating your newfound fans scott
shared in 2003 about his struggle with
such questions saying i was like nah
being the funny guy that's not why i
came to la but i appreciated it and i
realized that this is really just a
blessing to be able to make people laugh
when a comedy becomes as successful as
american pie it's only a matter of time
before talk turns to a sequel pi
presented a pair almost immediately the
first of these arrived in 2001 under the
name american pie 2. a smash hit its
success got american wedding greenlit
which would arrive in 2003. suddenly the
franchise wasn't about teenage sexual
escapades anymore but instead watching
the characters navigate various stages
of young adulthood through it all
stifler remained an anchor of immaturity
who could always be counted on for crazy
antics and ill-advised situations
scott admitted in 2003 i don't know why
people like the character it's because
of the way his friends played off that
character because if they would have
dismissed him and just treated him as
another doll as an audience member you'd
be like whoa he's just a jerk but they
just play with him and they accept what
he does
you're very unpleasant individually know
that
while films like 2001's jay and silent
bob strike back in 2003's old school
cast scott and supporting roles he also
got plenty of opportunities to become a
leading man in 2003 he was cast opposite
fellow rising star dwayne the rock
johnson in peterborough's so-so the
rundown he also signed on for 2005's
high profile reboot of the dukes of
hazzard despite a massive ad campaign
dukes bombed both critically and at the
box office a string of ill-conceived
comedies followed many trying to
recapture that stifler magic 2007's
american loser cast him opposite
gretchen mull as a rudderless adolescent
adult that same year mr woodcock put him
opposite billy bob thornton as an adult
looking to get revenge for his
adolescence 2008's the promotion had
scott competing with john c reilly to
get past the adolescent ways that had
stopped them from advancing in their
careers
in 2008 however scott made a dent with
paul rudd on one of his first star
vehicles role models trying to put some
space between his model's character and
stiffler scott said at the time
he's not really mean to anybody he's
actually a very optimistic guy but
clearly the whole physicality of it and
that vibe is very similar but i had
wanted to add something that made him a
little more irreverent role models
earned significantly better reviews than
hazard in scott's other films of this
period and also fared better at the box
office but still now a decade after his
american pie breakthrough sean william
scott was still trying to overcome the
same typecasting limitations
like many other comedic actors before
him sean william scott tried to branch
out with more serious films it was a
smart endeavor but unfortunately it
seems he may have just bet on the wrong
horses his big high profile leading man
play was undoubtedly bulletproof monk
the 2003 film was based on a comic book
it was also the directorial debut of
in-demand
[Music]
to answer that question ask yourself
when was the last time you heard anyone
talk about bulletproof monk around the
same time he signed up for what was a
very in-demand movie southland tales it
was filmmaker richard kelly's feverishly
anticipated follow-up to donnie darko a
movie that seemed to have announced the
arrival of hollywood's newest auteur
unfortunately the production became
notoriously troubled the film was
rumored to be largely incoherent and
after years of delays was released with
little fanfare in more recent years
scott has appeared in the grisly
thriller bloodline and a crime drama
already gone but neither of them fared
much better
in 2010 sean william scott kicked off a
new decade by connecting with one of the
most prolific names in 1990s indie
cinema filmmaker kevin smith probably
seemed like a safe bet as did starring
opposite the legendary bruce willis what
scott most likely didn't anticipate
however was a troubled production that
had the original title dropped against
smith's wishes the director and leading
man coming to despise each other and the
entire experience being so miserable
that smith hasn't made a studio film
since
scott was however one of the funnier
parts of the finished film despite
cop-out faring poorly with critics and
the box office it did earn the actor a
dream role well maybe smith even
considered his collaboration with scott
to be the inspiration he needed to push
hit somebody a hockey comedy based on a
warren zevonne song across the goal line
in 2010 smith explained sean for me was
the key into the character this dude has
something in him that you can just see
hang so well on buddy he's got some pain
that's going to work out well as you may
have guessed hit somebody has still not
made the leap from the page to the
silver screen it was going to be two
movies then one movie again then a mini
series and eventually smith just read
the script on his podcast in 2018.
whether the film is ever resurrected and
whether scott will still play the part
seems doubtful at this point fortunately
if you want to see scott in the world of
hockey we still have his two goon films
in 2013 sean william scott returned to
the role that had made him a household
name with american reunion it was the
fourth installment of the franchise and
had the american pie gang returned for
more raunchy escapades this gave scott
the opportunity to return to the role of
stiffler now a decade older but only
marginally wiser
yeah that's perfect scott didn't need
any compulsion to come back to the
franchise that made him in fact
according to him it was his idea he
shared it was a long time in the making
because i pitched the movie three years
ago the idea of bringing everybody back
for a high school reunion i said three
years to go wow how much fun is it going
to be to play stiffler in his 30s it was
a blast two decades after his american
pie breakthrough scott is still a
working actor although it's hard to
argue that any of his several dozen
roles has come close to stiffler as far
as mass appeal and awareness in 2018 he
took over the lead role in the fox cop
show lethal weapon though he was coming
on to a program brought with behind the
scenes drama scott's presence on the
show gave it a much needed positive
boost in publicity intriguingly scott
apparently pursued the role himself once
he saw that the show's original lead
claim crawford had been fired by the
program though lethal weapon with scott
in the lead role lasted just one season
that wasn't the end of his tv work later
in 2021 he'll be back on the fox network
with welcome to flatch a docu-comedy
that aims to be the office for small
town america a comedic project flash
seems like it could represent a
fundamental shift in scott's career as
he plays an authority figure and the
lives of some younger troublemakers
perhaps this is the beginning of sean
william scott reinventing himself as a
middle-aged actor whose days of
frivolity are behind him
it has now been well over two decades
since scott's life was changed forever
through the antics of stifler in
american pie though it has had its ups
and downs he has insisted that he has no
regrets about the career launching role
scott said in 2018 i didn't think martin
scorsese was going to cast me in his
next movie i understood why i wasn't
getting cast for other things i would
have been a distraction i kind of
pigeonholed myself but i felt really
lucky to get the chance to make people
laugh given that the combined worldwide
grosses of his movies have exceeded 1
billion dollars it is hard to feel too
bad for sean william scott some gambles
have paid off others have not but talk
to any actor and they'll most likely
tell you they'd be happy to have a
decades-long career with more than 30 tv
and film projects under their belt as
scott himself put it in 2018 i just got
lucky with american pie that movie gave
me a career
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]